dans la vie est parfois on travaille on
passe son temps à prendre des
décisions
et ce qui les rend souvent difficiles
c'est qu'il ya toujours une part
d'incertitude ou bien de risque dans le
résultat
par exemple
vous décidez de souscrire ou pas une
assurance qui ne vient à une extension
de garantie
vous jouez au loto peut-être bien vous
fait le déplacement
ou bien tout simplement vous vous
demandez s'il est raisonnable de prendre
l'avion sachant qu'il a une certaine
probabilité de ce crash
aujourd'hui on va voir comment notre
crétin de cerveau résonne quand il
doit prendre une décision avec une part
d'incertitude
commençons par expérience très simple
je vous propose le choix suivant
soit je vous donne 500 l'ont tout de
suite
soit une thérapie ou face
et je vous donne mille euros effacent
que je vous donne rien
qu'est-ce que vous préférez
face à un choix de ce jour la
quasi-totalité des gens de plus de 80%
choisi de prendre et ça sent le rôle
de ne pas jouer à pile ou face
et pourtant voilà comment on peut
analyser ce problème
dans le premier cas je gagne 500 go ok
dans le second cas je gagne soit 0 qui
soit mieux à 50% de chance
vous voyez qu'en moyenne ça fait ça
sent le roussi
on pourrait penser que les deux choix
revient au même et pourtant non les
gens préfèrent majoritairement le
choix certains mots risqué
et ça va même plus loin que ça
puisque même quand on augmente un peu
la valeur du choix risqué
et bien la majorité des gens continuent
de préférer le choix certains
pour voir ça on va retrouver les
expériences de mes deux auteurs
préférés d'entrer dans le cerveau
cammalleri de versteeg
ils ont proposé à des sujets le choix
suivant
soit recevoir 3000 $
cela sert pas
soit recevoir 4000$ mais à seulement
80% de chance
en moyenne le choix risqué et plus
attractif puisque 80 % de technip sa tec
3200 $
et pourtant les quatre cinquièmes des
genres ont pris le choix certains et
seulement un cinquième le choix risqué
intuitivement on pourrait se dire que
c'est parce que la nature humaine
n'aiment pas l'incertitude
le fait de ne pas savoir exactement
l'avancé conséquences de nos actes nos
décisions
et pourtant ces explications et tient
pas
regardez sur cet exemple
cammas diverses qui ont retourné le
problème imaginons que vous preniez une
grosse amende
vous avez le choix entre deux options
soit payé 3000 $ avec certitude
soit avoir 80% de chances de payer 4000
$
mais 20% de chances de ne rien payer du
tout
qu'est-ce que vous préféreriez vous va
nettement
et bien dans cette expérience 92 % des
gens ont compris le choix incertain
risqué
même si semble être le moins
intéressant qui sont en moyenne fait
père 3200 $
cette expérience montre bien que le
problème n'est pas que les gens fuient
les décisions risquées ou bien qui
comporte une part d'incertitude
au contraire là il se jette sur le pion
à l'issue très incertaine
et pourtant ce qui est fascinant c'est
que les sommes en jeu sont exactement
les mêmes que dans l'expérience
précédente
simplement dans cette expérience on
parle d'une perte pour lui d'un bien et
c'est ça qui modifie complètement
notre attitude face aux risques
quand il est question d'un bien les gens
ont tendance à fuir les options
incertaine a préféré les choix
certains
on parle d'aversion au risque
mais quand il est question d'une perte
les gens ont tendance à préférer les
options risqué
on parle d'appétence pour le risque
et ça ça se produit même quand les
deux options comportent une part
d'incertitude
par exemple qu'est-ce que vous
préférez
gagner 3000 $ avec 90% de chance
gagner 6000 $ avec 45% de chances
en moyenne c'est totalement équivalent
avant la deuxième option combien de
fois plus mais la probabilité est deux
fois moindre
les deux options comporte une part de
risque
n'est pas la même
et les gens choisissent à 86% la
première option la moins risquée
maintenant si on reprend le problème
qu'est-ce que vous préférez
pernaut 3000 $ avec 90% de chance ou
bien perdre six mille dollars avec 45%
de chances
et bien là 92% des gens compris le
choix le plus risqué
le fait que notre attitude face aux
risques ou incertitudes changent selon
qu'on parle de garou de pertes
peu paraître un peu irrationnel
mais la théorie de l'économie
comportementale permet de l'exprimer
commençons par les situations de guerre
est un élément essentiel à prendre en
compte pour comprendre notre attitude
face aux risques
c'est l'idée de perte de sensibilité
ou bien
sylla tout de suite vous donne à lyon
car le faire très plaisir
mais si je vous donne 30 millions
et puis que finalement je vous annonce
non c'est pas 37 31 millions
honnêtement ce million supplémentaire
vous en foutez un peu
à lire un million sera pas la même
valeur suivant ce qu'il possède déjà
amusons-nous à traduire cette idée de
valeur des biens avec une mesure de
plusieurs ou de satisfaction
les économistes - moussa vente sans les
appelle ça le l'utilité
si je vous donne 500 recours mais tant
que ça aux faces une satisfaction de
doutes
si je vous donne plutôt deux fois plus
1000 euros
pour le plaisir sera pas doubler un ça
sera moins que 24 tête seulement 18
à 1500 rôle ils ont 22 langues
et puis à 2000 euros mais donc voué
une satisfaction de 24
la cour de satisfaction en fonction du
bien augmentent de moins en moins vite
on dit qu'elle est comptable
et c'est ça c'est la concavité de
cette courbe satisfaction qui explique
pourquoi on préfère les guerres
certains
ou bien frisquet et même si ce rêve
équivalent en moyenne
si je vous donne mille euros selon cette
courbe autre satisfaction serait 18
mais si je vous donne soit 2009 soit 0
à une chance sur deux la voix de
satisfaction sera enfin de kate moss
héros
donc seulement 12 en moyenne
avec des cours de cette faction conclave
la satisfaction moyenne est toujours
prêt à faire ailleurs dans le choix
risqué
même pour un gain moyen rangers aux
pieds l'identique
de manière générale la comptabilité
des cours de cette faction c'est-à-dire
le fait qu'on devient de moins en moins
sensibles à une augmentation des gardes
et qui sait parfaitement pourquoi on a
une aversion au risque
et qu'on préfère les choix certains
plutôt que les choix risqué
a du moins quand on parle de guerre
parce que quand on parle de perte et
marcelle inverse
de même qu'on devient de plus en plus
insensible à un gain supplémentaire on
devient de plus en plus insensible aux
pertes
si je perds mille et un jours incertains
des plaisirs
mais six paires 2020 jouera pas le
double de déplaisir ans ça sera un peu
moins
cette fois on dit que la courbe des
pertes et convexes
et si je raisonne sur des choix risqué
qui se passe l'averse de ce qui se
passait sur les biens
le choix risqué est en moyenne plus
attractif que le choix certains
vous voyez donc que notre comportement
en apparence paradoxal de fuir le risque
quand il s'agit de dire que de le
rechercher quand il s'agit de pertes
c'est très bien à partir de deux
ingrédients
le premier combien le voir c'est cette
idée que l'on devient de moins en moins
sensibles aux gares et aux pertes
qui se traduit par la forme des cours de
ces dix actions
et le deuxième il est très important
c'est le fait qu'on juge toujours les
choses en relatif
comme des gares ou des pertes par
rapport à notre situation de
référence
cette dépendance à la référence sur
n'avait parlé dans une vidéo
précédente et on a eu quelques de
conduire à se faire passer facilement
manipuler
et bien quand on rajoute des choix
incertain on risquait
c'est encore plus paradoxal
kaman et diverses qui ont soumis le
problème suivant
une épidémie se déclare et 600
personnes sont touchées
vous êtes en charge de décider du
traitement leurs administrés et vous
avez le choix entre deux possibilités
traitement à 1 200 personnes seront
sauvés
traitement belz il avait une chance sur
trois que les 600 personnes soit sauvé
mais deux chances sur trois que personne
ne soit
face à ce soit 72 % des gens
préfèrent le traitement à le choix
certains
et puis un autre groupe de sujets on
soumet le même problème avec des
traitements différents
traitement ser
400 personnes vont mourir
très demandé une chance sur trois que
personne ne meurt et de la chance sur
trois que 600 personnes meurent
hélas 78% des gens préfèrent le
traitement des sommets qui est risqué
ces résultats sont totalement
cohérents avec ce qu'on vient de voir
quand on parle de bien les gens
préfèrent les choix certains mais
quand on parle de pertes les gens
préfèrent les choix risqué
le hic c'est qu'en fait les deux
situations jeunes vous décrire son qui
exactement les mêmes
regardez le traitement or c'est la même
chose que traitement ser
et le traitement bms est exactement le
même que le traitement des cas
le simple fait de présenter les
chiffres différemment en parlant de
choix de personnes qui survivent soit de
personnes qui vont mourir
a fait passer les gens d'un comportement
on vous disait que le risque
un comportement du prêtre des risques
et ça rien qu'en changeant les mots
utilisés
tout ce qu'on vient de présenter la
requête assez bien la manière dont la
plupart des humains se comporte en
situation d'incertitude
et pourtant il ya un truc qui cloche
si cette analyse était parfaitement
correcte
personne ne jouera jamais au loto
mais l'auto rend gros c'est une
proposition du genre
pays est pas un euro pour avoir une
chance sur un million de gagner un
million d'euros
c'est-à-dire une perte certaine
pour un bien en moyenne pour mieux lui
qui va l'en mais très incertain
la baston bien de voir qu'on devrait
totalement fuir ce genre d'offre
et pourtant il ya plein de gens qui
jouent au loto ou à des jeux d'argents
comment expliques ça
une des raisons avancées par cannes
manette vers ce qu'il dit
c'est le fait qu'on a beaucoup de mal
apercevoir les probabilités
pas seulement les calculs et
numériquement et même quand on nous
donne les chiffres déjà calculé
a correctement les interpréter et à
les prendre en compte à leur juste
valeur
et notamment dans le raisonnement on a
une tendance naturelle à surestimer les
faibles probabilités alors donné une
importance exagérée
il a une expérience qui montre ça
très bien qu'on appelle le paradoxe
d'année
on a vu tout à l'heure contre 6 euros
à 45 % de chances et 3000 euros à 90%
de chance les gens préféraient
majoritairement le choix le moins
risqué
mais imaginez que vous propose le choix
suivant
6000 euros à zéro virgule 1% de chance
de 3000 euros à 0 22% de france
au fait c'est quoi
là si vous êtes comme la majorité des
gens vous choisissez l'option à 6000
euros
et c'est un peu paradoxal parce que la
situation est la même que
précédemment
une option à l'autre on a deux fois
moins de chances de gagner
mais un d'un potentiel de fois plus
élevé
donc logiquement notre attitude devrait
être la même
intuitivement l'explication sait qu'on a
du mal à faire la différence entre 0
1% et 0 2%
quand on voit ces chiffres 1 3000 euros
à 0 2% du 6000 euros à 0 1%
ça a l'air d'être un peu près la
même probabilité de gagner
donc on choisit le gain potentiel le
plus élevé de 6000 euros
pour bien mettre en évidence le côté
paradoxal de la faire on peut faire une
troisième expérience
on propose aux gens le jeu suivant il se
déroule en deux temps
première étape du jeu là vous avez
rien à faire rihanna a décidé que
c'est juste un tirage au sort
et vous n'avez que 0 2% de chances
d'aller à la deuxième étape
si vous atteignez la deuxième étape
vous aurez le choix entre 3000 euros
avec certitude
ou bien 6000 euros à 50% de chance
on ne sait pas encore si vous allez
aller à la 2e étape le tirage au sort
a pas eu lieu
mais vous devez dès maintenant choisir
ce que vous exprimer au cas où vous y
alliez
version propose cette situation jours
ils vont faire abstraction de la
première étape qui ne maîtrisent pas
et raisonné sur la deuxième
et ils vont choisir majoritairement
l'option la moins risquée logique
et pourtant prions globale se joue en
deux étapes est exactement le même que
celui de vous présenter avant
au final on doit choisir entre 0 1% de
chances de gagner 6000 euros
nous avons 2 % de chances de gagner 3000
euros
pour une situation confina le parc
attenant identique le simple fait de
décomposer différemment les
probabilités c'est que les gens peuvent
passer de l'option la plus risquée à
l'option la moins risquée
canal exerce qui on le sait comprendre
ça emmené le strand la manière dont
on déforme les probabilités dans nos
perceptions
sur ce graphique jour présente la
probabilité perçu mon ressenti si vous
voulez
en fonction de la probabilité réel
quand les trois unités sont faibles on
a tendance à ne pas bien faire la
différence et avait surestimé
donc notre probabilité perçu ressemble
à ça
et c'est pour ça qu'on continue à
jouer au loto parce qu'on surestime la
probabilité réelle de gagner qui est
minuscule et je crois que c'est une
chance sur 14 millions avec l'auto
classique
évidemment on commet l'erreur inverse
avec les pros il était proche de toi
si je vous dis que quand vous prenez
l'avion nous avec 99 les bulles 9 9 9 9
9 % de survivre et que quand vous prenez
la voiture vous avez 99 véhicule neuf 9
9% de survivre
vous allez vous dire c'est à peu près
la même chose et pourtant ça n'est pas
du tout
donc pour les probabilités proche de
moi on apprend aussi cet effet
d'écrasement qui fait qu'on les
considère qu'un peu tout pareil
on n'arrive pas à se convaincre que
quelque chose comme le fait de survivre
en avion et quasi certain
à ce stade on pourrait penser que ce
phénomène de déformation des
probabilités
il est lié au fait qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à manipuler des très petits
chiffres comme des milieux viennent
en fait on n'a pas besoin d'aller jusque
là pour que l'effet se manifeste
canal exerce qui ont fait l'expérience
suivante à leur première expérience
3000 $ avec certitude ou de 4000 $ à
80% de chance qu'on s'a de là on l'a
déjà vu
et 80 % des gens près le choix certains
et son expérience
3000 $ à 25 % 4000 $ par un pour cent
et bah déjà là les attitudes sont
renversés
20-25% bateau beaucoup c'est pareil
alors que 80 ou 100 % mais c'est pas
pareil et pourtant les races sont les
mêmes mains
et comme tout alors qu'on pourrait
réécrire la seconde expérience en
deux étapes
première étape tirage au sort avec un
quart de chances de passer à la
deuxième étape
et ensuite soit 3000 avec certitude ou
alors 4000 à 80% de chance
donc vous voyez qu avec des
probabilités pas du tout négligeable
une chance sur 4 ou 5
le phénomène de déformation de
perception se manifeste déjà
il modifie notre attitude face aux
risques et à l'incertitude
au final notre courbe qui représente
les probabilités ressentir en fonction
des probabilités réel
elle ressemble en droit ça dans les
extrêmes
et puis rentre le d'obernai à peu près
bon pour percevoir les probabilités
même si on peut imaginer que l'opa de
variantes à cette courbe
au final cet effet de déformation de
nos perceptions des probabilités
fait qu'on peut avoir une attitude face
au risque qui est différente de celle
que prévoyait l'analyste précédente
et par exemple on peut accepter des
pertes certaine
comme payer un euro pour jouer au loto
dans l'espoir de bien très incertain
donc n'arrive pas correctement assimiler
la probabilité
on entend parfois que l'auto c'est une
sorte d'impôt sur les gens qui ne
comprennent pas les probabilités
mais ce normand de cannes avec sa fille
c'est pas tellement une question de
compréhension mais plus qu'une question
de perception de pondération
quand je vous dis que vous avez une
chance sur 14 millions de gagner au loto
mais là rien à comprendre n'ya pas de
matha feria pas calcule
c'est juste une question de correctement
intégrer cette probabilité dans nos
raisonnements
et c'est ça qu'on a du mal à faire
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter
l'assuré d'une danse que kamal exerce
qu ils vont appeler la théorie des
perspectives
vous savez au début de la vidéo de
vous expliquer qu'on pouvait analyser
les choix incertain qui comporte des
probabilités
en regardant ce que ça rapporte en
moyenne
si vous avez une probabilité de 5% de
gagner mille et une probabilité de 95%
de perdre 100
hélas le résultat moyen 7 5% 2000
+95% d'au moins 100 ça fait moins 45
morts en moyenne c'est pas très
intéressant
alors petite note un peu plus le début
des études termes de moyenne
mais les mathématiciens ont un mot pour
sarah isabelle salle l'espérance du
bien
en faisant abstraction
dans ce genre de choix on considère la
probabilité de téhéran d'avoir un
résultat extra
et une probabilité pédo d'avoir un
résultat qui laisse deux
et les résultats bruts des diapositives
ou des pertes négative
l'espérance est donc fait un foyer de
sein+ paix de police de
quand on évalue l'intérêt de ce choix
on a vu qu'on juge pas
proportionnellement les gains et les
pertes
mais à cause de notes diminution de
sensibilité d'art intuitivement on les
remplace par la satisfaction que nous
apporte ce qu'on a appelé l' utilité
on peut appeler cette fonction le pérou
on a vu la forme qu'elle pouvait avoir
et enfin quand on évalue les
probabilités dahan s'est pas non plus
correctement les prendre en compte et
ont découvert par une fonction s
qui écrasait probabilité faible est
élevé
et donc voici ce que nous dit la
théorie des perspectives
quand on nous soumet à un choix
incertain qui comporte une part
d'incertitude
on effectue bien une sorte de moyenne
intuitive avec les probabilités
sauf qu'on déforme à la fois les gares
et les pertes mais aussi ses
probabilités
ce qui est étonnant dans tout ça c'est
qu'au final on l'a vu on peut avoir des
comportements qui sont qui est rationnel
face aux risques qui dépend de la
manière dont on nous présente les
choses
et pourtant la théorie des perspectives
montrent que ces comportements
irrationnels
ils sont reproductibles on peut les
mettre en équation et c'est à dire
qu'ils sont d'une certaine manière
prédictible
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
veut dire qu'on peut les étudier
scientifiquement
mais ça pose aussi le risque de se
faire manipuler avec
donc essayer de penser à ça la
prochaine fois qu'on vous propose un
choix avec une part d'incertitude
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne
rien rater des prochaines vidéos ou
contournée par les éditions
précédentes notamment toutes celles de
la série crée par le cerveau
vous pouvez suivre les actualités de la
jeune fille qui certifie les comptes qui
souhaitent soutenir sur cette liste
at-il ajouté